thank you thank you all so much for
coming out to join us today uh I'm here
with my uh house partner uh
congresswoman slotkin uh from Michigan
and we will once again reintroduce the
gun violence prevention research act uh
we are here today because we are tired
of tragedy because we want to save lives
this important legislation will help us
do that by ensuring that there is
funding at the Centers for Disease
Control and prevention on firearm safety
and gun violence
prevention we know this is not a Panacea
but it's a piece of the puzzle that for
20 years was barred because knowledge is
power and for too long the NRA and their
acolytes in the United States House and
Senate wanted to take the power away
from the people no one knows this better
than the gun violence researchers and
Advocates who are here with us today
including Shannon frateroli from the
Johns Hopkins Center for gun violence
Solutions and Greg Jackson from the
community Justice organization who will
tell you just how critical funding for
gun violence prevention research is in
their life-saving work today we're also
welcoming to the capital uh students who
have experienced firsthand the horrors
of the gun violence epidemic that
plagues our communities from our schools
to our streets Devin Woodruff
Michigan State University student Dylan
Morris an Oxford High School student
Elia Eastman
Marjorie Stoneman Douglas High School
shooting Survivor and co-founder of Team
enough as well as March for our lives
advocate in American University a
student
Anam Hussein so far in 2023 Americans
have witnessed and experienced the
Carnage of more than 130 mass shootings
just this week another mass shooting in
Tennessee took the lives of three
innocent nine-year-old girls and three
adults how many more lives must be lost
before Congress has moved to act how
many more families must be torn apart
how many more communities must be
shattered by the trauma of gun violence
we need a federal assault weapons ban
now we need Universal background checks
now we need red flag laws Nationwide now
we need to hold gun manufacturers
accountable for their deadly products
now we need to keep guns out of the
hands of dangerous people now and we
need to invest in the research to guide
evidence-backed data-driven solutions
that will help save lives but for more
than 20 years a rider to the the 1996
Omnibus Appropriations Bill the Dickey
Amendment blocked the Centers for
Disease Control and prevention the CDC
on nation's top public health research
agency from conducting gun research
uh from conducting prevention research
in our country putting blinders on our
best researchers and avoiding the
science that could help us stop gun
violence never made any sense in the
first place for years with the support
of gun safety Advocates I have led the
fight against this deadly self-imposed
ignorance in 2020 uh perseverance
finally paid off beginning in fiscal
year 2020 through fiscal year 2023 we
secured 100 million dollars in gun
violence prevention research funding at
the Centers for Disease Centers for
Disease Control but we shouldn't have to
wage in Appropriations battle every
single year in order to most effectively
respond to our nation's gun violence
epidemic and fill the data gaps caused
by Decades of inaction we must authorize
increase and regularize gun violence
prevention research funding with the
limited money we've secured since 2020
the CDC has funded research to enhance
our understanding of firearms injuries
develop Innovative prevention strategies
and evaluate the efficacy of strategies
to safeguard individuals families
schools and communities from firearm
related harm whether it is studying how
to best Implement extreme risk
protection order laws or how to prevent
firearm suicides we must invest in this
research because by doing that we will
gain a better understanding of the root
causes of gun violence and identify
evidence-based Solutions in order to
prevent it with the right funding
research at the CDC we can help to bring
an end to the epidemic of gun violence
in the United States a crisis that
affects all Americans regardless of age
race or political affiliation
communities barely have a moment to
mourn before gun violence takes the
lives of more Americans more children
more parents more brothers sisters
friends mentors these are statistics
these are people
it is time for us to act for every
single City and town across the country
suffering from gun violence today
we must now work even harder we put a
assault weapons ban in place in 1994 it
expired in 2004.
by 1996 they were back again the NRA to
put a ban on Research we now
are doing that research and we need more
funding so that's why we are here today
and that's why I am just so proud to be
able to partner uh with the great
congresswoman from the state of Michigan
uh congresswoman slotkin welcome
well it's an honor to be here with
Senator Markey who has been an
incredible Advocate on this issue for
quite a long time
um
I want to talk a little bit about
um as I stand here with all these
Advocates about our experience in the
state of Michigan just over a month ago
I became the first congresswoman in
America to have two school shootings in
her District
and what's particularly devastating is
that these tragedies were 16 months
apart in November of 2021 a deeply
troubled high school student opened
fired with parents gun at Oxford High
School and killed four of his fellow
students
last month on February 13th a gunman
walked through the campus of Michigan
State University terrorizing students
putting all of East Lansing on lockdown
forcing a Manhunt and murdering three
young michiganders wounding five others
before killing himself and on Monday
another mass shooting at an elementary
school in Nashville resulting in six
deaths including three nine-year-olds
gun violence is now the leading cause of
death for people under 21.
that's not politics that is just fact
and while the news will move on from
each shooting take it from me our kids
and our families who are first forced to
endure pain and Trauma that will stay
with them for the rest of their lives
I've seen it firsthand at vigils and
funerals Community meetings with
students and teachers and First
Responders the need for long-term
counseling and the fear of public places
that emotional weight from these
tragedies is crushing
what we have in front of us is a choice
do we as adults want to step up and do
something to fight the biggest threat to
our children
or are we at this point willing to
ignore the greatest threat to our kids
to make this point we're joined here
today by two students from my district
Dylan Morris one of the students from
Oxford High School
who was there at the day of the shooting
and Devin Woodruff a student at Michigan
State who was on campus and in the
Student Union the night of the shooting
at msu's campus both of them are here
today I'm so grateful for them and their
bravery in speaking up and choosing to
help lead the way in addressing this
crisis they are turning their pain into
purpose and I'm immensely proud of them
as a former CIA officer and Pentagon
official I want to be clear that
preventing gun violence is a matter of
Homeland Security
the job of anyone in Homeland Security
is to protect U.S citizens in the
Homeland and the bill we're here to
unveil today is part and parcel of
protecting American citizens
quite simply the gun violence prevention
research act would help give the CDC the
tools they need to study the root causes
of gun violence and help shine a light
on the steps we can take to make our
community safer
as a michigander I'm particularly proud
that one of the academic institutions
that does this very kind of critical
research is the institute for firearm
injury prevention at the University of
Michigan
now the U.S government has long studied
and gone after the killers of children
the most clear comparison I can make
today is on seat belts and car seats in
the 1970s and 1980s back then the number
one killing killer of young children was
car accidents no seat belts no car seats
the CDC studied why why were so many
children losing their lives in these car
accidents and the studies were
fundamental to a U.S physician-led push
to mandate car seats
and eventually seat belts with the help
of that data from the CDC we decided to
go after the number one threat to kids
and what we are announcing today is the
very same thing our children are being
traumatized and killed in their
sanctuaries and as you will hear they
are asking for our help
as elected officials who have sworn
sworn an oath to protect and defend the
United States I can think of no higher
responsibility than her to protect our
children this should not be a partisan
or divisive issue it is the job
description of a U.S representative
and while certain members of Congress
here in DC have not yet gotten the memo
the ground is shifting on this issue and
Americans of all Stripes including and
especially gun owners Hunters sportsmen
are demanding basic gun safety measures
that will help save the lives of their
children
in Michigan our state legislature is
listening to the demands of the public
for basic safety measures like Universal
background checks safe storage laws and
extreme risk protection loaders we are
poised to pass this Monumental
legislation in the next couple of months
the two school shootings we've had make
it clear that there is no contradiction
between being a responsible gun owner
and caring deeply about protecting
children
lastly to my colleagues who refuse to
consider any gun safety legislation
if you're so sure that other gun safety
legislation that and that any gun safety
legislation is bad you should at least
be willing to study the problem and get
the data you say you need
to do something to protect our kids
thank you again to Senator Markey to our
activists who've put in their sweat and
their time to this issue and I'll now
hand it over to our Michigan State
Student Devin
thank you congresswoman uh good
afternoon everyone my name is Devin
Woodruff I am a proud student at
Michigan State University I'm glad to be
here with you all today and to focus on
keeping students safe I spent a lot of
time at the MSU Union I call the MSU
Union my home
um at that time
that was when a gunman opened fired and
in at the end of the night three of my
fellow students had been killed my night
uh it it it turned upside down I ended
up that night crying not knowing what I
was gonna do that whole night ended up
calling my mother telling her I didn't
know how I was going to move next my my
home that I called the Union uh was uh
effectively ruined by a gunman yeah the
union would never feel the same it would
never be the same I wish that these
tragedies happen less frequently but as
the news of Nashville on Monday's show
this is becoming more of a normalized
part of life in the United States and as
kids and students like me who are paying
the price of the inaction of DC
politicians who are frankly in my
opinion scamming us more than a month
after the shooting in MSU we at MSU were
struggling students are struggling we
don't know how to feel safe on campus
even with the wounds that we're healing
Spartans families will never be the same
I I use a saying that my mother always
says is that kids should always come
home should always come back home and
that can't be said for the Spartans
lives that were lost gun violence is the
leading cause of death for kids in
America and until we start treating this
like a Public Health crisis kids aren't
going to feel safe in their communities
and in their school
we can't settle for thoughts and prayers
anymore we need concrete action to help
save lives including bills that are
talked about here today studying gun
violence as a Public Health crisis is
the best possible way to understand the
root cause of this epidemic and how we
can combat it the gun violence
prevention research act will boost the
cdc's research into gun safety and give
us new strategies that will stop mass
shooting this kind of Bill shouldn't be
partisan
it shouldn't be partisan at all
we need to make sure that we are keeping
students and everyone safe
I really want to make sure that we we
move upon the front that every
everyone's life matters and we need
Congress to act now but I sincerely want
to thank congresswoman slacken and
Senator Markey for advocating for
students because they're truly doing
their job unlike some of the people in
these Congressional Chambers who are
just collecting a check and not actually
doing action and wanting to save our
lives but I thank you congresswoman
slacken for actually doing the work and
wanting to make sure that students are
able to go to school get an education
and live thank you
Dylan Morris from Oxford High School
good afternoon I want to thank
Congressman slatkin for having me here
today my name is Dylan Morris and I am a
student impacted by senseless gun
violence I'm a senior at Oxford High
School in Oxford Michigan and the
executive director of no future without
today a 501c4 social welfare initiative
to curb gun violence
on Tuesday November 30 2021 a student
fired an unsecured handgun he had
brought from home in the hallway at
school during a passing time he murdered
Hannah St Juliana tatemere Justin
chilling and Madison Baldwin and wounded
seven others that afternoon I huddled in
the corner of my English classroom
we were to begin reading a short story
by Hurricane murakami but instead we
were ready to defend ourselves if anyone
came through our door
my classmates and I frantically grabbed
makeshift weapons including scissors
tape dispensers and a hockey stick
anything we could find at the moment
is this America's idea of freedom it's
not mine
it shouldn't have been a school day for
my classmates and me it should not have
been a school day for those students and
Educators in Nashville either three
children three young children and three
adults were murdered at an elementary
school on Monday many more were
traumatized and a community is now left
shattered gun violence is the leading
cause of death for children in teens in
the United States
we need
we need to move Beyond thoughts and
prayers and take bold action we know
that we need a universal background
checks law and national safe storage Law
And A Renewed assault weapons ban but we
also need research to finally address
this as the Public Health crisis that it
is
for decades the lack of federal
investment in research and data
collection on gun violence despite its
increasing prevalence has been failing
communities around this nation
and as a high school student I'm taught
to use data and research to back up my
arguments but the federal government has
made it impossible for States Community
organizations and researchers to
adequately tackle this problem
the contents of the gun violence
prevention research act will help us
create evidence-based solutions to this
epidemic and save thousands of lives
every year
and I ask the people in the building
behind me who may not fully grasp the
reality of what we're dealing with here
to picture their lives without their
children picture their lives without
their loved ones their spouse picture
their faces on the news
nobody is immune to the effects of gun
violence anymore I now personally know
students and young people in Michigan
who have survived two mass shootings
it's no longer a matter of if you'll
experience the effects of gun violence
it's a matter of when
it's no longer it's it's it's not
permissible it's not okay
and I'm I'm grateful for representing
the slotkin and Senator Markey for
leading this effort and I urge members
of Congress from both parties to help
get this bill over the finish line so
that we can start to treat this crisis
with the seriousness that it deserves
thank you
[Applause]
Leia
good afternoon everyone and thank you so
much for having me here today
my name is Elia Eastman and I'm an
organizer and co-founder of Team enough
and a current senior at Trinity
Washington University
at the age of 22 I have been having this
conversation over and over and over
since the age of 16 I have been forced
to relive my trauma nearly every day due
to the inaction of this country
I'm talking about the senseless but
preventable gun violence in America
I survived the 2018 Valentine's Day
tragedy at Marjorie Stillman Douglas
High School in Parkland Florida
where 14 of my schoolmates and three
administrators were killed
I was in the third classroom attacked by
the perpetrator and I'm only here today
because of Nicholas Dore who in death
protected me from bullets as they
shattered our classroom laptops windows
and walls
faster than four minutes 17 beautiful
Angels were robbed from our community
and another 17 more are left with the
physical scars from that day for the
rest of their lives
34 people were shot in total and that
does not include the emotional and
psychological damage gun violence leaves
behind that we are all forced to clean
up ourselves
but Parkland is just one of over 300
fatal school shootings since Columbine
and it's not just schools we see this
violence at churches malls parades
grocery stores and every single day in
our streets
this year alone there has been
exceedingly more mass shootings than
days
in the month of March we have
experienced over 57 fatalities and it's
only been 29 days of this month so far
we know that this violence is not
inevitable and that there are common
sense public supported Solutions
and that's why I'm here proud to support
Senator Markey and representative
slawkin
for the reintroduction of the gun
violence prevention research Act
this bill would fund research at the CDC
on firearms safety and gun violence
prevention legislation it is a critical
step in understanding the root causes of
gun violence and developing effective
solutions to prevent it
we cannot ignore the recent tragedies
that have taken place in this country
two days ago
just two days ago we witnessed yet
another devastating mass shooting at an
elementary school
in elementary school
in Nashville Tennessee where at least
three children and three adults lost
their lives
three children lost their lives
Evelyn daikenhaus
Haley Scruggs
Willian Kenny
all at the age of nine years old
in the place that they're supposed to
feel the safest
children are fighting Wars in their
classrooms with no protection
we have States like Florida
that don't even want to arm us with
books and knowledge
they are busy rejecting things like
critical race Theory instead of
protecting children from shootings
the new purpose of school in America is
death and Trauma
meanwhile dangerous legislation is still
being pushed through Tennessee in
Florida
expanding permalist carry
permanent open carry for all firearms
including assault style weapons
we know that that will not keep us safe
we cannot allow
these Reckless and stupid policies to
continue
and we can't continue to let our leaders
fail us
they failed those three nine-year-old
children
they are failing us
failing children that are trying to
learn
innocent people are being slaughtered by
weapons of war and this country
continues to do nothing about it
if our leaders cannot prioritize Public
Safety and invest in research that will
keep us safe from future strategies then
they do not deserve a job
[Applause]
vote them out
thank you
for joining us in supporting the gun
violence prevention research act and
let's work together to change the course
and culture of gun violence in America
thank you
Now Greg Jackson executive director of
community Justice action fund
first and foremost thank you to the
members of Congress for having us here
today my name is Greg Jackson I'm the
executive director for the community
Justice action fund and I don't come
here about choice I come here by
circumstance in April of 2013 only nine
blocks away from here I was shot and the
bullet that hit me to hit two arteries
and while I was bleeding to death being
transported to the hospital when I
arrived at the hospital I wasn't met
with activists and survivors and
supporters I wasn't met with my doctors
or nurses I was met with investigators
and I went through three rounds of
Investigation while I was fighting for
my life
literally bleeding to death
when I finally met my surgeon he said I
only had 26 minutes left to live
I almost lost my life while being
investigated for a crime and in America
we are in a world where we are thinking
about solving the crime first and saving
the life second
and that crime only approach is
destroying our communities
gun violence is a Public Health crisis
that requires a public health approach
since I was shot a hundred thousand
people have been shot every single year
that means nearly a million individuals
have been shot
and these are more than numbers for me
this includes my family friend Trey who
was shot and killed in Greensboro North
Carolina my mentee Quran who was shot
and killed two weeks after hosting his
own stopped the violence rally here in
Southeast D.C and so many countless
others
gun violence has become the number one
cause of premature death for all youth
in America but it's been the number one
cause of premature death for black youth
since 2006.
this is the number one cause of
premature death for all black men in
America number two cause of premature
death for black women and for Latino men
in America
but yet we haven't seen the action that
we need we have not seen the solutions
that we want and we have not seen the
Investments that we need in our
communities to address this crisis
research is key because it allows us to
figure out what we do not know but
there's a lot we already know
one thing that we know is that this is
the least research cause of death in
America of the top 30 causes of death
the least research
there's more research around sepsis
y'all probably have to look that up
right there's more research on that than
there is on gun violence as a Public
Health crisis
and we know that research equals
Solutions
we also know that there are
evidence-based strategies that don't
have enough Federal support to be passed
programs like Community violence
intervention programs hospital-based
Services victim Services cognitive
behavioral therapy programs so many
strategies that are very cost efficient
that if properly invested and supported
in could save lives today but don't have
the enough research backing to get the
support needed in Congress
we also know that gun violence has a
real cost every year we're losing over
557 billion dollars from our economy due
to the impact of gun violence that's a
very high price tag and often you'll
hear leaders say well we don't have the
money for it or like yesterday we can't
fix it but if you knew that you could
save 557 billion dollars I think there
would be a little bit more energy in
Congress to get something done
there's a couple things that I really
want to emphasize is that we have the
Solutions in our hands but we don't have
enough research or activism or urgency
in Congress in order for us to get this
done
and so I want to thank these Congress
folks for uh for stepping up Senator
Markey congresswoman slotkin for
investing research and pushing forward
and giving us the solutions and the
background that we need to advance the
solutions that we know save lives thank
you
next we're going to hear from Shannon
prateroli a researcher at Johns Hopkins
University
good afternoon everyone Senator Markey
thank you for having me here
congresswoman slotkin thank you very
much
I'm humbled to be here with this group
today whose high school and college
Years have been punctuated by gun death
and who have responded with such courage
and determination
my name is Shannon frateroli I'm a
professor at the Johns Hopkins Center
for gun violence Solutions where for
more than 20 years I've used Public
Health tools to develop Implement and
evaluate strategies designed to prevent
gun violence
up until recently Federal funding to
support this type of work was almost
non-existent
efforts to identify Solutions were
limited to a small community of
researchers supported by a dedicated
group of private funders who were quite
frankly outmatched by the sheer size and
scope of gun violence in this country
over the past 20 years while Federal
funding has been out of the picture more
than 650
000 people have been killed by guns in
the United States
they've died by Suicide they've died by
homicide including intimate partner
homicides and by unintended gunfire in
communities all across this country
many more survived to being shot but
sustained life-altering injuries and
Untold trauma
even more have lost loved ones to gun
violence
over the past 20 years as the number of
lives lost to gun violence has increased
I have watched year after year as
talented early career researchers rise
to meet the challenge that is gun
violence prevention only to turn away as
they realize that without Federal
support for this work the chance to make
a meaningful impact is almost impossible
the absence of federal support for gun
violence prevention research means that
for decades we as a country have missed
opportunity after opportunity to
understand the full scope of the problem
and to study refine and Implement
informed solutions that could have saved
countless lives
but times are changing
in the years since Congress began to
support gun violence prevention research
missed opportunities are being replaced
with funded research designed to make a
difference
both NIH and CDC have funded research
projects that are up and running today
I know this because I'm the recipient of
one such Grant
and I know that the findings from this
newly funded research will provide
guidance to communities local
governments state and federal agencies
and other service providers about how to
reverse the upward Trend in gun violence
that has increased at an alarming rate
since the pandemic began
to meet the challenge that is gun
violence in the United States we must
continue to invest in federal research
dollars in order to make up for an
entire Lost Generation of gun violence
prevention research
those Investments need to continue if we
are going to realize a future where high
school and college students come to the
nation's capital to celebrate their
accomplishments and participate in
democracy rather than mourn their
classmates and loved ones and heal their
traumas
I'm here to assure you that the gun
violence research prevention community
and the larger community of public
health researchers are already rising to
the challenge to identify solutions to
our country's gun violence prevention
gun violence problem
continued Congressional support for that
work is an essential step and I thank
you for your efforts to realize that
goal thank you
next we're going to hear from Anam
Hussein
welcome
[Applause]
hi my name is Anam Hassan I'm a student
at American University and I'm here
today speaking on behalf of March for
our lives Firearms are the leading cause
of death for children and teens in the
United States for students like myself
that means we have to live constantly in
the shadow of America's gun violence
epidemic often we are told by passive
elective officials who aren't interested
in Saving Lives that gun violence
prevention policies do not work even
though they have been proven to save
lives both abroad and in the U.S
this lock of initiative from elected
officials is wise there has been a
complete underinvestment in research and
data that surrounds gun violence in our
country
without up-to-date data on gun violence
apathetic officials can pretend gun
violence is not our reality and they are
helpless to solve this issue that is why
I am so grateful today to be here with
real leaders and partners in this
movement Senator Edward J Markey and
congresswoman Caroline B Maloney as they
reintroduce the gun violence prevention
research act to fund research at the CDC
on firearm safety and gun violence
prevention
funding for gun violence research is
critical for our fight to end gun
violence today is the 88th day of the
year and our country's already been
through 129 mass shootings the headlines
from this past week read Chicago
shootings 12 shot to fatally and
weakened gun violence across City
another reads how to talk to Children
about school shootings after six people
were killed in the Nashville shading
two children orphaned by gun violence in
Louisville over the weekend and this is
only to name a few this is the United
States's current reality but it doesn't
have to be this way CDC research on gun
violence prevention will help us build
out evidence-based Solutions and it's
one tool in our fight to end gun
violence in this in the U.S and change
our nation's reality
thank you
thanks so much Senator Markey had to run
and vote he's on his way back but we're
happy to take questions from the press
for any of our speakers who are up here
today thanks for coming
why do you think a public health
approach is the right approach to take
with gun violence well first of all I
mean as you've heard
um you know when something is the number
one killer of young people under 21 it I
think it deserves to be researched and
understood in a scientific way and
particularly to get at the root causes
but secondly I think the public health
part of it is is obvious when you see
particularly in urban settings the way
that you'll have one person shot and
then three piercing people shot and then
five people shot it's similar to a
public health risk that you might see
coming from disease or illness and
particularly in communities that have
long dealt with gun violence there's a
pattern to some of these things
particularly in retributive violence so
I think that there's a there's an
obvious connection to uh to science and
to understanding that is an issue
because if you know my peers are
constantly saying well this piece of
legislation isn't going to work or this
piece of legislation isn't going to get
at it well if they're so convinced that
not once single bill of the hundreds
that have been produced are actually
going to do anything then at least allow
us to study it and have some data if
that's a true argument that they're
making so I think it's um clear and as
you heard that was a new fact for me
that it's out of the top 30 ways that
Americans die it's the least researched
I thought that was a a stat that speaks
for itself
who knows
good clap thank you
yes sir
message to Congressman like Tim burchett
who said we're not going to do anything
to stop school shootings I it's it's not
it's not hard to understand when the
number one killer of children under 21
is gun violence and legislators who are
elected refuse to talk about gun
violence that's not a hard equation to
understand that means that they are so
scared of their base they are so scared
of being primaried from their right they
are so scared of losing the Privileges
of this job that they would have rather
ignore it wait for the cameras to go
away and live another day then do
something to protect children and as
someone who just like these guys swore
an oath to protect and defend the U.S
Constitution
um it is at my at this point for me
dereliction of Duty for these folks to
refuse and I'm not saying we have to
agree on every single bill that's not
what this place is about this place is
about debate and negotiation and
compromise but they refuse to come to
the table they refuse to offer their own
ideas they refused to acknowledge the
base problem so I I um I'm look I'm a
Democrat who represents a Republican
leaning District that is I grew up with
guns I feel you know we have a ton of
folks who believe passionately about the
Second Amendment but that does not mean
that responsible gun owners don't also
want to protect their babies in schools
and in their communities
yeah what else
have you spoken to any Republicans about
this research ability of any a reason to
believe uh they would be on board with
it you know uh last Congress we had a
number of very brave Republicans who did
vote on a lot of legislation on
Appropriations related to gun violence
from my own state of Michigan we had
Fred Upton who is retired unfortunately
many of those Brave Republicans aren't
back in Congress so the people that we
always went to who were sort of the
Leading Edge on on bipartisanship on
this issue have either been primaried
and are not here or they've chosen to
retire rather than be in a climate
that's that's this um uh polarized we
have constantly reached out to our
Republican colleagues begged them to
come to the table on something as simple
as universal background checks right
you're going to buy a weapon go through
a background check you say you care
about mental health and you think that's
the problem great let's do a background
check for people who buy guns on the
internet who buy guns at a gun show but
their resistance is to every every
single Bill and that to me tells me
they're not serious they're not ready
for a real conversation they're just
here to enjoy the Privileges of this
place and not do their job and protect
young people
yeah anything else for our speakers
[Applause]
well I know Senator Mark he's probably
hustling to get back here as fast as he
can I don't want to hold people you say
oh you see them okay well we'll now
we'll all stare at him awkwardly as he
walks across the Plaza
and he's doing his duty he's doing his
job to vote
and we'll see if there's any questions
for the senator
well let me hatch the other
organizations here to come up and speak
and talk about how to get involved all
right hey so first things first if you
want to get involved with Community
Justice action fund you can follow us at
CJ actionfund www.cj actionfun.com
excuse me we also have a really
important research project called the
city violence prevention index report
where we looked at the top 50 cities
most impacted by violence and assessed
what are they investing in to address
violence Beyond policing and we're
seeing that a lot of cities are not
investing in Trauma Centers and Trauma
care they're not investing in access to
uh resources they're not implementing
anti-bullying policy so we encourage you
to look at that report to learn more
about the strategies and what we're
trying to build on with this research
for any young people that are interested
in getting involved you can go to
www.team enough.org and for any older
parents or grandparents that want to get
involved you can go to
www.bradyunited.org
beautiful
we've gone through a few questions
I'm sure they have questions for you as
well any questions
okay yes sir the congresswoman was asked
if she had had any conversations with
her house colleagues around this
particular piece of legislation I'm
curious if you've talked to any of your
Republican Senate colleagues about
pushing something like this forward to
see if there's a possibility that this
could have been experience well in past
years uh congresswoman Carolyn Maloney
and I
um we had to work the Appropriations
process which is what congresswoman
slokkin and I are now going to do and
we're going to work it throughout the
course of the year as it unfolds we've
been successful the last a couple of
congresses and our goal is to ensure
that we do it once again we want 50
million dollars a year for five years in
a row research is medicine's Field of
Dreams from which we harvest the
findings
that give the information we need in
order to prevent the unnecessary deaths
that is occurring in our country right
now and we're very optimistic that we
will be successful once again and
congresswoman slotkin is a hero in the
house and she has an incredible story to
tell from our own state but there are
many other stories from every other
state and we intend on capitalizing upon
that politically to get the funding
which is going to be necessary because
research without funding is an
hallucination so we have to get that
funding made available
thank you all so much thanks for being
here
thank you
again